este vídeo está pensado para toda la
gente curiosa que se quedó con la duda
de por qué la pendiente de la recta del
margen de ingresos es el doble a la
pendiente de la recta de la demanda no
en todos los casos pero estamos
suponiendo que la demanda es una recta
para que se cumpla esta propiedad ahora
bien este es un vídeo opcional y repito
opcional no tienes que entender
forzosamente todo lo que está explicado
en este vídeo voy a usar conocimiento
del cálculo y espero que te sirva
bueno pues supongamos que esta es la
recta de la demanda y recuerden que yo
lo que quiero probarles es que la recta
del margen de ingresos tiene el doble de
pendiente
estamos en el plano cartesiano donde
comparamos al precio con la cantidad y
bueno si estamos comparando el precio
con la cantidad y hablamos una recta
entonces podemos dar la ecuación de esta
recta recordando un poco lo que vieron
en geometría analítica una de las formas
para escribir una recta era que es igual
a mx + b donde m es la pendiente y b era
la ordenada al origen aquí no tenemos ni
x ni game pero tenemos el precio y
tenemos la cantidad por lo tanto voy a
escribir la recta como
es igual a m m es la pendiente
por q mas b a veces le conoce como la
ordenada al origen es decir donde cortan
mi recta al eje del precio y bueno m
recuerden que es la pendiente que por
cierto la pendiente está dada en un
cambio de p con respecto a un cambio de
q es decir la pendiente es lo mismo que
el cambio en p dividido entre el cambio
en q bueno ahora me voy a tomar el plano
cartesiano en donde yo comparaba el
ingreso total con la cantidad recuerden
que lo hicimos hace tres vídeos en uno
de los ejes está el ingreso total y en
el otro de los ejes está la cantidad
ahora recordando la definición del
ingreso total que por cierto es lo mismo
que precio por la cantidad voy a
escribir el ingreso total con una
función de la cantidad lo primero que
voy a hacer es sustituir a p recuerden
que ya tenemos una función que comparaba
a p con q que es la recta que teníamos
originalmente por lo tanto sustituyendo
a p me va a quedar que es m por q lo que
teníamos de la ecuación de la recta que
multiplica a su vez a kun
y esto es el ingreso total ahora voy a
distribuir aquí entonces el ingreso
total es igual a m cuadrada + b por q y
aquí hay una cosa que hay que notar muy
importante recuerden que la pendiente de
esta recta es negativa sino recta está
decreciendo por lo tanto tiene una
pendiente negativa es decir m es menor
que cero y eso me está diciendo que
entonces si yo quisiera graficar el
ingreso total a comparación de la
cantidad me va a dar una parábola porque
es una ecuación cuadrática pero no es
cualquier parábola es una parábola que
abre hacia abajo porque m es negativa y
además que pasa por el origen porque
cuando yo sustituyó a q por cero obtengo
que el ingreso total es cero y bueno ha
llegado la hora de hablar del margen de
ingresos el margen de ingresos lo
habíamos definido como la pendiente de
la recta tangente en cualquier punto de
la curva del ingreso total es decir
desde un punto yo les voy a dar la
pendiente de la recta tangente
en ese punto sobre mi curva del ingreso
total y esto nos lleva al cálculo porque
cuando yo hablo de la pendiente
la recta tangente realmente de lo que
estoy hablando de la derivada del
ingreso total con respecto a q es decir
la derivada es lo mismo que la pendiente
de la recta tangente y derivar esta
función de q no es tan difícil para esto
hay que recordar algunas propiedades de
la derivada primero m es una constante
es un numerito por lo tanto cuando yo
derivo q cuadrada me da 2 cubo pero 2 q
que multiplica m me queda 2 m por q
ahora voy a derivar de q sin embargo que
también es una constante es un numerito
que me están dando
y cuando yo derivó una constante porque
solamente obtengo en la constante es
decir más b y bueno esta derivada es lo
que yo había definido como el margen de
ingresos el margen de ingresos es esta
curva que está aquí o mejor dicho es
esta recta que está aquí porque tiene la
misma forma que una ecuación lineal
tenemos a b tenemos a b es decir esta
recta corta al eje del precio en b y
tenemos una pendiente de 2 m la
pendiente es 12 m a comparación de la
otra pendiente que era simplemente m y
con esto que les acabo de decir
se nota que la pendiente de las rectas
del margen de ingresos es el doble a la
pendiente de la recta de la demanda es
decir su gráfica se va a ver algo así
porque recuerden que las dos pendientes
son negativas tanto la pendiente de la
recta del margen de ingresos como la
pendiente de la recta de la demanda de
cualquier manera si entendiste esta
demostración yo me voy a sentir bastante
bien porque acabas de realizar una
prueba matemática y si no entendiste
nada no te preocupes puedes seguir con
tu vida y pueden seguir viendo los
vídeos de esta lista pues no volver a
utilizar el conocimiento de cálculo